All right. Uh, welcome everyone. Uh, so
today, uh, things may look a little bit
different. Um, so I'm not sharing my
document camera like normal. Instead,
uh, we have three guest panelists, or
hopefully we're going to have four guest
panelists. There was another one who,
um, uh, who we thought might make it.
Uh, and we'll see what happens. Um but
uh yeah, I'm excited to welcome uh all
of these recent UCSC grads who took
distributed systems this course when
they were students at UCSC and have
since graduated and are are off in the
world doing amazing things. Uh so we
have um Emma Gomeish, Pete Wilcox, and
Lawrence Lawson. And I'm going to ask
each one of them to introduce themselves
and uh and talk about themselves for
about 60 seconds or so. Um and then
we'll proceed to do a panel. So I have
some canned questions that I want to ask
all of them. Uh but if you have
questions for them uh students in the
class, uh or people on Twitch for that
matter, uh you can. So you can ask a
question in chat uh or um you can if
you're in the Zoom meeting you can ask a
question uh by audio if you want to as
well. Um so with that uh let's get
started. So um let me ask uh Emma to to
introduce
um yourself first and um just tell us
like for 60 seconds or so um a little
bit about uh who you are and what you
do.
Um, hi everyone. Um, I'm Emma. Um, and I
graduated in, uh, last year, 2019. Um, I
graduated with a BA in computer science.
Um, but I walked in commencement with
the game design program. I I sort of
crashed the program in my senior year. I
I just I walked into their capstone uh
year-long class and um basically offered
my services as a producer um for a video
game team and one of the teams took me
on and I've been doing that ever since.
So I'm actually still working with the
team uh that I graduated with uh right
now. We formed a company and we are like
actively seeking uh like publication.
Um, and so I've been a producer for a
video game development team for about a
year and a half now.
And this is the game that you uh that
you began development of as a student,
right?
Yes. Yes, it is.
And are are you Emma? Where are you? Are
you based in LA?
Yeah. Um, I moved out to LA with a
friend of mine that I graduated with.
Uh, because there's there's a lot of
video game development out here. So, um,
they work down in Pia Vista and I work
at home.
Cool.
All right. Um, and next we have Pete.
Uh, yeah, I'm Pete Wilcox. Uh, I also
graduated last year, uh, with a BS in
computer science and, um, now I in the
PhD program in computer engineering at
Santa Cruz. Um, I'm in the center for
research in storage systems with Hiner
Litz. So I'm doing uh systems work um
and uh mostly I work on storage
accelerators and storage networks. Um
yeah, that's about it for me.
So you moved right from uh being an
undergrad at joining the PhD program,
right?
That's right. I did. Um I had a really
good relationship with my uh computer
architecture professor who I suspect a
lot of your students also took this
class. Um and uh there's uh there was an
opportunity to uh jump right in and um
get started on some industry sponsored
research work that he had. Uh and so I
took it.
Cool. All right. Um and last but not
least, uh we have Lawrence.
Hey, uh my name is Lawrence Lawson. Kind
of feel like I'm in an interview right
now.
Um, so I'm a machine learning
infrastructure engineer at uh at a tech
startup called Beyond Limits here in
Glendale, LAish area. Um, I graduated
last year um with a BS in computer
science. Um, when the world is normal, I
usually go to tiki bars in Disneyland
and, you know, go to work and every
everything as as well. Um but right now
um obviously working from home and doing
this and also
um trying to figure out how to make it
easier for people to style their turnups
on on Animal Crossing. So making our
rest API to scrape the turbage website
which is really fun.
Um but yeah, that's a little about me.
Cool. Um, and what I recall about uh
about your so all I I believe all of
Lawrence and Pete and Emma took um
distributed systems from Peter Alvaro in
uh in fall 2018. And then they were all
part of my course staff uh in the the
following spring uh spring 2019 last
spring. And if I recall, um, I remember,
uh, Lawrence, you saying that the the
stuff you did in the class had a direct
influence on you getting hired to do the
job you're doing now.
Yeah, definitely. Um, so the I I don't
even remember like how or when I applied
for the job I have now because when
you're like your in your senior year,
you're just applying to everything, you
know, and it's just like I don't even
remember and then they call you back.
And one of the things I real I
recognized is that the part of the tech
stack was was Golang and when Pete and I
were in a were were partners in the
class um for in one of our the the
choices we made were were to like
instead of using Python or a different
language or Java it was like hey we
don't know Go let's learn Go and the
rest is history from there and that
really helped because not only like a
lot of like the core concepts of like uh
class help but like we really made a a
real application using the language. So
we got a real like you know we just dive
right really really really deep in that
kind of like showed like um a depth and
a breath of of the knowledge of like
that language and and a lot of the shy
systems concepts that I think a lot of
undergrads don't really have and that
for the places that I interviewed at
they're pretty impressed by.
Yeah. Um something that I've noticed is
that so a lot of undergrads don't take
distributed systems at all. It may not
be offered at a lot of places and um
certainly some of the stuff that that we
cover in this class which is the design
of this course is uh is is Peter's I
mostly stole his course design uh
covering uh especially covering things
like consensus protocols and so forth.
Um it's rarely covered at the undergrad
level. Uh I certainly didn't learn it
when I was in undergrad. So um uh I
think that that can make you stand out
as a as an applicant. Um okay so some
people are starting to u post some
questions on our our course Slack
already. Um so and and also uh Emma a
comment for you. Um somebody comments
that Squish was great. Uh Squish was the
game that Emma and their team developed.
Um and um and so then also here's a
question uh for Emma from another
student. Um, does your team have funding
for the game?
Um, we got a little bit of funding. We
actually were awarded a grant from UCSC
when we graduated. Um, and we we
received another small grant from UCSC
um, while we were in school. Um, and we
are trying to make that money last as
long as possible. Um, so we have very
little in the way of funding. We're all
currently um some people are working
other jobs, some people are like living
at home and just trying to scrape by. Um
we've actually lost a lot of team
members because we we can't pay our team
um a salary amount. So um we're about
down to half the size we were when we
graduated because uh people have been
getting jobs in other places that
actually pay money.
So what about you? Are you working
full-time on the game?
Yes, I I work full-time on the game. I
um was a dedicated uh producer, which is
a video game equivalent of a project
manager um throughout the school year.
And then um a couple months after uh
graduating, I transitioned to doing
programming as well. So, I'm I also work
like directly in Unity. And I handle all
of the uh Git repository stuff because
Git and Unity don't really like
interacting with each other. I do all
the builds. I run play tests. Um, I uh
work with publishers, all that sort of
stuff.
Interesting. So, um, so I have a couple
of questions u that are kind of specific
to the game uh uh but or or specific to
to kind of what you just said. Um, so
this the this interaction between Git
and Unity is interesting. So, do game
devs not typically use uh version
control like Git? like do do tools like
Unity have their own built-in uh
versioning or how does it work? I know
nothing about this.
Uh yeah, Unity does have its own um
version control that I think is based on
git called um collab which I've heard is
pretty bad.
Um I from what I understand the industry
standard is to use perforce which is
very old version of system and works
somewhat differently. It's not the same
like underlying architecture as git at
all. Um, but really the only problem
between Unity and Git is that Unity uh
generates a lot of YAML files um
whenever it compiles and whenever it
runs. And so those generated files um
have to be in your version control
because they they have like unique
identifiers and Git can't really process
um like generated files very well.
They're like thousands upon thousands of
lines and they they we check in things
and it's like 11,000 lines changed in
this one YAML file and so when there's a
merge conflict we essentially can't
can't deal with it have to just discard
one set of changes. That's that's why
there's the um they don't play well
together.
So, kind of to bring things back to
distributed systems, uh, so does Squish,
your game, have online play, and if so,
is that something that you've
contributed to?
No. And I we we talked about it at the
end. Um, we were we were talking with a
publisher and they had a requirement
like it needs to have online play if
they're going to pick us up. and we had
a we had a long brainstorming talk with
all the programmers and um concluded at
that time there just there was no way we
we'd be able to implement it. Um at that
time I wasn't involved in the
programming side and only one other
person on the team had taken distributed
systems. So it was like sort of big
scary thing but now I have this what is
it called a JJO to look into. So, um I
that that's been I've been ramping up
that's like my weekend's project is to
try to figure out how to get net code
into our game because I would love to be
working on distributed systems again
because I don't have a lot of
opportunities to work directly in code
distrib distributed systems.
Yeah. Um uh GGO um it's uh it stands for
it stands for good game peace out. Um
but um but but it's it's the name of
this um uh rollback networking library
that's used by uh by a lot of games uh
for the and and it's so that I'm looking
at their website now ggpo.net. Um so
they say it's designed to hide network
latency in fast-paced Twitch style games
which require very precise inputs and
frame perfect execution. And um so I'm
fascinated by this topic and I'm also
fascinated by the fact that um there's
so there's a whole lot of work I think
that goes on in gamedev that um
mainstream software developers I think
could learn from. Uh but it that
learning tends not to happen uh because
um game developers have their own
distinct vocabulary for a lot of things.
So these game devs are solving really
hard distributed systems challenges uh
in creative ways. Um but that knowledge
doesn't necessarily make it to the
larger software development community uh
because um either because um the the
code isn't open source or because um uh
uh game companies don't want to talk
about what they do to make their game
good. Um or even just like even if the
code is open source uh um just the way
in which it's it's documented and
discussed tends to use this entirely
different like uh set of of vocabulary
than um than mainstream software
development does. Um so um so GTPO is
actually it's it's publicly available uh
on GitHub. Um so um uh you can uh and
it's I think MIT licensed. Um uh so I
think that means that if you want to use
it in a in a for-profit project uh then
you have to um uh you have to contact
the developer um about about other
licensing. Um but but yeah, it's it's
it's really cool. You know what little I
know about it, it seems really cool. Um
the idea is that um uh
if you um uh if if you're playing online
um there there's obviously this this
network delay. So roll back networking
will try to predict um what the other
player will do and uh it'll it'll run
your inputs locally and it'll try to
predict what the other player will do
and if then if that then turns out to
have been wrong then it will roll back
to whatever point in the game state uh
uh that that it was at and and continue
from there once it receives the remote
inputs. Um, but it turns out that um uh
the the input prediction can be pretty
good and most of the time this can can
provide uh something that feels a lot
like offline play for a lot of games. Um
so um yeah, it's it's it's really cool.
Uh let me see what other uh let's see if
there's anything else uh being asked
here. Um so um some somebody else also
asked about uh another question for
Emma. Um does UCSC own part of the
rights to the game?
No, we investigated this near the end of
the school year and um the game design
program like the the folks who were
involved in the like administrative side
of the program, the professors um
actually it seems like have made ma made
an effort to ensure that um our games
are completely our own. So uh UCSC has
no ownership of it. It's completely
ours.
Cool.
All right. Um so
let me try to bring um Lawrence and Pete
into the conversation some more. Um so I
want to talk about um um about your
experience. Uh Lawrence, you mentioned
you're you're a machine learning
engineer. So um somebody actually asked
um so on our start of course survey uh
so I I surveyed everybody at the at the
beginning of of this course um about um
you know what questions do they have
about about the course or um or or about
distributed systems or anything and uh
one of the questions that was asked um
uh had to do with with machine learning.
Um so somebody asked let me let me bring
up the actual question that they asked.
Um
um so the question the question was um
um what sort of what sort of ML
applications exist in distributed
systems. So um I have some thoughts on
this but I but I'm I'm I'm curious about
like what your work uh is and what it
what you do that's kind of in the
intersection of machine learning and
systems.
Yeah. So, I'm not sure if this really
would like, you know, answer that
question, but
okay.
The kind of the the work that I do is
kind of let me try to try to think of
like a flow for so we have data
scientists who just kind of like write
code to like you know make some sort of
to write some sort of model, right? And
a lot of times it's just a lot of just
like different scripts and littered
across like some sort of codebase and
then they pull up a Jupyter notebook and
then they run it once and it's like I
guess it works and it's nothing nothing
short of like you know a lot of like
graduate student kind of code or
whatever just to show like hey here is a
concept it works and but the problem is
is that like okay we're actually making
production level code and we need to
actually make this into something that's
going to be usable.
Yeah. So to be clear, just so that the
undergrads in the course know, when
Lawrence says graduate student level
code, he means bad code.
We're not known for good code.
Um, but the way that I kind of look at a
lot of machine learning applications is
they're just, you know, obviously
there's a lot of like, you know, math
when it comes to it, you know, where
there's a lot of like, you know,
hardcore machine learning techniques and
everything, but like when it comes down
to it, it's mostly just like really like
um either data intensive or just like
compute intensive applications that just
like take a lot of time to crunch
certain numbers. And when we're what we
noticed when we're deploying like some
of these applications um to any kind of
cloud service that we're not doing in a
very um intelligent way where it's just
like they'll be these really really like
you know compute intensive applications
in like one node and there will be like
eight people even it's like such a low
number hitting this one one instance and
it will just come to like you know come
to a crawl just like I can't like you
know function. So we have to think about
like okay we have to like either
replicate this whole entire application
um how do we do so in like a much more
intelligent way but even so I was
thinking about what I'm doing now
actually I'm lead initiative is um how
do you make it easier for for for the
data scientists at our company to not
only have the same kind of like um low
overhead of
writing code, how they're used to
writing code, but also being very easy
to
quickly spin up and deploy and also be
scalable, whether it be horizontally or
or vertically. Um, and there's an
there's a framework that's used at
Netflix called Metalflow that I
discovered. Um that what's really cool
about it is that it provides a lot of uh
of quality of life uh tools when it
comes to scaling horizontally and
vertically where you can think of like a
machine learning pipeline where have a
series of steps and because of the way
that the the the framework works you can
actually say that certain steps of that
pipeline could be even different um
compute environments entirely. And the
way that we were writing code and
deploying code before that would have
been almost impossible because we would
have to write every single step of the
machine of their of the machine learning
pipeline in its own little microser and
deploy that and it'll be in that
computer environment. Um but what we
most likely do is package everything
together including like you know um the
back end and like the front end too. And
it was like this big monolithic you know
piece of software and we had to kind of
choose like the compute environment that
was best for like the most intensive
part of that pipeline which is not ideal
like you don't for most of the pipeline
you don't need a GPU but because because
this because step like X2 needs
something that's really compute
intensive we have to deploy and scale
out from that point instead of just
scale out just the or scale up just that
section of the pipeline. So, I'm kind of
working on not only making it easier to
scale up and scale down on demand for
for different applications, but also
still making it easy for um the data
science developers to actually just
write their code like they do normally
because I think a lot of times they they
kind of get scared off by a lot of
um I guess like software engineering
types of of writing code and just like I
like a lot of people I've met at the
company just don't like using Git, but
they have do. Um so even like getting
them to do something as simple as like
you know using get you know at least for
us simple um is kind of a headache. So
kind of like spoon feeding them and
trying to make like
um the overhead so much lower to adopt
new technologies so they can still do
the same work is kind of really
important for me as well.
Yeah, I mean that's a great point. There
are so many things about what you just
said that I that I want to riff off of.
Uh but just that last thing that you
said about about um uh about Git. So
this kind of relates also to to Emma's
earlier point about how Unity and Git
don't play nicely together. Um notebooks
and Git don't play nicely together
either. And uh this this problem of how
to properly version Jupyter notebooks uh
which are now the de facto standard for
anybody who's doing data science right
in industry. Uh this problem of how to
to properly version them is is kind of
an open problem. And um this is
something that I personally struggled
with last quarter because I was teaching
a new undergrad course we have here uh
CSSE30 uh which is taught uh entirely
using uh Python notebooks um hosted on
collab which is uh which is Google's
hosted environment for Jupyter notebooks
and um so we're developing these
notebooks um and I was working on them
together with other faculty members and
uh we didn't have any good way of of um
of versioning them properly, right?
There's there's like some hacks that you
can do, right? Like you can use like you
can use like git hooks to to strip out
the unnecessary stuff in the notebook.
Um or you know any changes that aren't
essential like the number of times a
cell has been run, that kind of thing.
Um but but this is just kind of a hack
to make um to make this thing that kind
of this thing that's meant to be
interactive, right? uh and is kind of
not intended to be used in this
traditional sort of linebased version
control sort of way. Um it it's it's
kind of a hack to make it that to to to
shoehorn it into that. So
yeah, definitely.
Um and I just find in other people's
like computers is like I don't know what
notebook it was working in. let me look
into like my my finder and it's just
like
it's just like horrifying to see just
working version 2.0 really working
version 2.0.
Right. Right. But on the other hand, you
don't want to impose a particular
workflow on people who have a workflow
that works for them.
Yeah.
So, um No. So, I guess I mean the
there's um the part of the part of the
challenge here um is is the stuff that
you just mentioned about version
control, but then there's all of the
other stuff that you mentioned about
scaling up uh machine learning and data
science uh to run uh in a distributed
fashion. And um that so so I'm glad you
brought up um Metalflow because I
actually hadn't been aware of it. Um
that's really interesting and it's
really cool that it's open source. Um
yeah.
So um
uh my so I my my partner likes to so he
works at Google and he likes to talk
about how Google is a machine for
turning machine learning problems into
systems problems. uh which is um
like a um kind of a a reference to how
like at at at Google um they they do
machine learning all day every day. Uh
but they're they're they're doing it at
at at a massive scale and this is
actually very relevant to what we're
going to talk about on Monday which is
map produce. Uh so map produce was uh
kind of the the first in a in a series
of frameworks that are that that are
intended to uh to help people solve the
kind of uh
um machine learning application problems
that Google has but at uh at a huge
scale. And so um
uh there of course there now exist um
open source versions of of those
frameworks.
Um
but um but it sounds as though Metalflow
is is addressing a slightly different
problem. Um, right. Like it's for people
who um uh who may not be systems
programmers
um at all. um who are so
um
it's kind of just like like like
balancing that like role of like
um I need to hire the best DevOps person
ever and also I need to hire the best
like data science scientist ever and
either they have to work really well
together or they have to be the same
person which is both impossible
and I think that um I think that you're
right you know like um a lot of machine
learning problems are just into just
boiling down to systems level problems.
But at the same time too um not every
company is Google right and not every
company has to has to solve Google level
problems
right right
even the very like you know small
companies have big problems that they
deal with because it's big in their
world
and for my company at least we don't
have like we make we make uh machine
learning applications
um for like other like clients
so it would be like really bigname
clients that are like either in like the
energy sector or the healthcare sector
or whatnot and usually their like user
base is like 10 and it's it's really
interesting. It's like okay well it's
like 10 people using this application.
You think about like most like web apps
or anything you know these days like
okay that will work but like it's not
just a simple web app. It's like
something that's like constantly like
going into pandas and then just like you
know crunching all these numbers in
numpy and then okay we're gonna ship it
off. we're going to go to this touch
this API that's going to like you know
some TensorFlow part of the flow
whatever like it it like ends up just
like ballooning really fast even just
for 10 people. So learning how to like
kind of scale that out and actually
be like again like another distributed
systems like you know buzz term be fault
tolerant is really important.
Yeah. You know, I I think something
that's underappreciated is the vast
difference between having one user and
having 10 users of a system.
Yeah.
Um so I want to bring Pete in also. So
um so Pete's experience uh is a little
bit different from from Lawrence and
Emma in that um Pete is uh is an
academic. Um so um but I but I think
Pete's work also is in this intersection
of of systems and machine learning. Um,
so, um, so Pete, I wonder if you could
talk a little bit about kind of how you
ended up choosing to go to grad school
and, um, and a little bit about what
you're working on now.
Um, well, I I chose to go to grad school
because, um, when I was in undergrad, I
took uh, classes uh, I took operating
systems taught by Daryl Long and uh,
computer architecture taught by Hiner
Litz. And they're both in this uh,
storage systems lab. And I really liked
both classes. I got along really well
with both uh professors and I got a
chance to uh meet with and chat with
some of their grad students and learn
about the the um systems that they're
working on. Um and uh I I thought that
those were really interesting. And so um
the work that um uh Hiner focuses in is
um architecture and systems and storage
work uh focused on data center
applications.
Um for instance uh what I'm working on
is storage accelerators that are going
to be used um on uh uh networks in um
data centers so that you can separate
the storage nodes from the compute nodes
and um in some in some sense you could
think of it like map produce but on
individual hard drives. Um and um so I
I'm really interested in this because um
I think that um one of the big pushes
that we need to make like sort of as a
society is to make our data centers much
more efficient than they are so we can
stop boiling the oceans. Um and or at
least make it not get any worse. uh and
uh that's the sort of thing that um
we're working on in in my lab is u more
efficient applications for uh data
center providers.
Um
and so the the sort of work uh that that
um like for instance what I'm working on
right now is a system to take uh uh
compute like a CPU or an FPGA um and and
colllocate it with the hard drive. And
so one of the ways that we when we're
talking about it with people is we talk
about map produce where um on when
you're when you're talking about a sort
of map produce system you would have
many many servers um with discrete
storage that they can um utilize and
over a very large network and we're
talking about doing that within one
server uh instead. So a much like lower
level problem
if hopefully I I don't know if you if
your class has read the map produced
paper yet.
We are actually reading it for Monday.
So
ah um
hopefully some of them have.
Yeah. So so um yeah we're going to be
talking about it starting on Monday. Um
uh yeah that's uh um I so so I don't I I
don't necessarily want to assume too
much knowledge of map produce right now.
Um
uh but um yeah we'll be talking about
map produce. Uh so so like a like I
guess a one one sentence description. So
so map produce is is a framework that
will allow you to um to plug in uh uh
pieces of code that will then be
automatically uh be distributed and run
in a fault tolerant fashion on many
machines in a data center. uh for the
goal of accomplishing um uh a variety of
tasks that Google was interested in
accomplishing in the mid200s.
Um uh this is um uh and and map produces
has has um has been succeeded by so if
you're familiar with with Hadoop or SM
or Spark um those are the open- source
uh equivalents of um so Hadoop is like
an open source equivalent of map produce
and Spark is um is its successor in some
sense um but we'll talk about all this
on Monday. Um I want to uh bring in a
few more questions that folks are
asking. Um uh so a couple of questions
for Lawrence. Um so um one person asked
um of what uh what are the distributed
systems technologies uh that you use? Um
and also uh for machine learning um do
you do you lean on machine learning
libraries or do you tend to to implement
things from scratch?
uh as far as like the machine learning
like technologies that we use uh
something something AWS I mean as far as
like a distributed systems technologies
we use something something AWS right
where just like
I think one of the biggest distributed
system I don't even know if this will be
in the same category
but one thing we're lean on specifically
for distributing um large compute loads
is um an AWS a service amongst like
millions of AWS services called AWS
batch which allows you to quickly spin
up in this isolated like compute
environment for like whatever you want
to throw at it whatever kind of numbers
you want to crunch but with uh some of
the applications that we're writing we
want to take think of like this one like
script of code right we want to actually
split up all this entire script into
like five different um container
containers. So how would you do that? So
writing using leveraging different
frameworks that help you containerize
pieces of code and then um send them to
a batch instance and having each of
those containers be like different like
you know either amount of memory memory
or how many or some one of those
containers have a GPU one of them has
like two CPUs and then all joining
together you know maybe in like a map
produce like type way where like here is
the final number here is a CSV that you
can show your boss and I'll be like
that's nice.
Um and then can you repeat the second
question one more time?
Oh um so uh uh for machine learning uh
are you are you relying on existing ML
libraries?
Uh yeah, I I think that everyone wants
to still stick with you know like
psychic learn and like you know pandas
and everything you don't want for so for
a lot of like the applications we write
we still use a lot of those offtheshelf
uh machine learning libraries and
frameworks.
Um we do actually have in-house uh
machine learning libraries that we use
and machine learning like uh microser
that we just do like API calls to to get
some sort of reasoning back. Um but so
for the most part everything that you
can like Google and learn yourself like
we're still using that today. So like
any of those things that you if you
taken a machine learning class and or
taking a AI class and you're they say
like here are some like Python libraries
that you use we still use that today but
we just really like mutate it to get
exactly what the results we were looking
for. Um so yeah so a lot of it so some
in-house mostly but mostly like the
standard libraries that you could find
in pipasol pretty much anywhere for
Python.
Yeah. Um uh so in the in the CSE30
course that I taught uh last quarter uh
we touched on machine learning a little
bit uh which was an exciting thing to do
for an intro course and um so what we
did was um uh
so an aspect of um of of uh any well not
any but many machine learning frameworks
uh is um uh automatic differentiation.
So, so what we did was um we we had
started by um by implementing in Python
uh just a just kind of a representation
for arithmetic expressions. And then
once we had that was like oh look you
can you can implement uh something that
uh that mechanically uh takes the
derivative of these arithmetic
expressions. Uh and then once we had
that, we realized we had most of the
pieces uh for implementing a toy machine
learning framework that did automatic
differentiation. Um uh although very
slowly
and um and not the sort of thing that
you would actually use in production,
but but once once we had the the auto
differentiation, then all you had to do
was kind of wrap that in gradient
descent and then you had this um kind of
slow bad ML framework. Uh, so it was it
was a fun thing to do. Um, but I also
and I'm and I'm glad that we had the
chance to do it. Um, but also I I want
students to understand that if you're
doing this in practice, then you would
never implement that stuff yourself. Um,
you don't have to build everything from
scratch.
Yeah. you you just have to you know a
lot of like software development um is
being like it's like playing with Legos
right where it's like you don't have to
make the Legos you don't have to like
like you know you know mold the actual
Lego itself in order to build like you
know a spaceship or whatever like you
you buy the Lego pieces and put them
together in really interesting unique
ways
right
I mean maybe that's a very crude way of
looking at software development and it's
it's definitely There's a lot more depth
there than that. But
no, I think that's a good analogy. I
mean, I think so. I I like that analogy
because uh it makes clear that there's
still a great deal of creativity, right?
Just like there's creativity in building
things out of Legos. Um even if you're
putting together preassembled pieces,
you can do it in infinite ways. Right.
Right. And like things like what Pete's
doing is like more of that I'm molding
the Lego itself,
you know? So, you can get really deep in
that. And uh so it really depends on
like you know what side of like
how how what side of the stack you're at
you know are you
going super lowlevel where just like
what is a Lego
right right yeah so speaking speaking of
um these low-level architecture
questions uh another question uh a
question for Pete um uh Pete do you work
with risk five and do you think that
risk 5 is useful in industry
um I think risk 5 is certainly useful Um
it's used in a lot of a a lot of uh not
uh PC applications but like a lot of
phones and and embedded systems and um
you know things that don't have
keyboards um use use risk 5 because
those chips are designed for efficiency
in a lot of ways. Um I don't work with
it. um there's some chance that I I
might um but uh what I work with is is C
and C libraries um uh in an operating
system level so in inside the kernel and
um using some some sort of standard
libraries for developing storage systems
um and uh there I'm on my project is is
someone else um who writes uh a language
called uh Verilog L which is used for
programming FPGAAS. Um and
uh and then we have somebody else who's
really good at Python. Um and what uh
our specific project is is trying to map
uh this sort of not not data scientists
but and we work with the the UCSC
genomics institute and so there's a
specific application which is written by
uh these um biioinformatics engineers um
in order to do genome mapping and um
we're taking this application and trying
to make it f run really fast on
specialized hardware And so it's this
code which kind of the same problem that
Lawrence is dealing with where you have
these people who software engineering is
not their their main focus. And so the
software that they engineer is maybe not
as elegant or or well written as as what
you might hope. Uh and we're taking that
uh this code that was written in some
higher level language and trying to
translate it down into something so that
we have pieces that'll run on
distributed uh architectures.
So, another question for Emma. Um,
again, uh, to do with, uh, funding for
the game. Uh, has the team considered
getting VC funding?
Um,
uh, not really, I guess. Um the there
I'm kind of the only person on my team
who is doing pretty much everyone who's
remaining on the team is um just a
developer. We have two artists and
oh one of our programmers is leaving so
we're down to four. Um we have two
artists and two programmers and I am
kind of filling the gap of everything
else. Um, so I'm I work with freelancers
and I work with publishers and I kind of
full up on work. So
yeah.
No.
Yeah. Looking for funding is itself a
full-time job.
Yeah.
As I know as a professor,
if you'd like to give us money, like if
there's anyone in this class who would
like to give us money to work on this
game, then we would love your money.
Um, is there a a free-to-play demo?
Um, there there's not right now. Um, we
are going to be uh participating in the
game showcase at UCSC since it's fully
online this year. So, uh you will be
able to play Squish
um during the Sammy Showcase, which is
is going to be during finals week. So, I
think the second week of June.
Oh, nice. Okay. All right. I will
advertise that. Um, cool. Um, all right.
So, I want to turn to a different topic.
So, um, so all of you graduated last
year and um and are are working either
for yourselves or or for someone else.
Um, and so a lot of my students are
graduating into uh what is now uh a um a
not very uh promising looking economy.
And I'm I'm wondering like what kind of
what kind of advice do all of you have
with the hindsight of of being a a year
out from graduation?
uh for somebody who's about to graduate
uh with a with a computer science degree
especially in the age of co 19 um what
kind of advice do you have for them on
on uh on job searching and life after
graduation?
I mean again a very heavy topic.
Yeah. Yeah. Not to be a downer here, but
um honestly I think my bit of advice
is just try to in some sense try to you
know proceed as normal where you're
still applying for jobs like don't not
apply for jobs. Don't not like, you
know, you know, polish your resume and
polish your LinkedIn and all those
things that you have to do in order for
a recruiter to say that, wow, you know
how to use a computer. Um, that's super
important. Um, other than that though,
you know, do everything you can to like
kind of like, you know, looking for a
job in even a normal world is the most
like stress one some of the most
stressful things you could do. And so I
can't even imagine doing the same thing
where like you don't already like have
like a job or have you know secure you
know money to like you know keep you
afloat. It can add another layer of
stress. So whatever you can do just try
to stay mentally sane. Take breaks. you
don't have to like constantly be
grinding like be grinding but don't
grind to like yourself to to like to the
bone where you're just like not even a
person anymore. Um so like yeah so I
would say yeah do some leak codes but
don't like do 400 leak codes in like a
week because like that's just going to
like ruin your like mental health. Uh
but still, you know, just kind of look
at like jobs and just kind of apply. And
I think sometimes a lot of people reach
out to me and ask like what they should
look at look for. And a lot of times I
just say like think about like the the
applications you already use and just
apply for those companies. And that's
kind of like what I did when I was when
I transferred to Santa Cruz. Like I was
just like, "Wow, I'm here now." And now
it's like actually really serious. Um
cuz like when I I sort of did a lot of
work to even get to a point where I
could transfer from community college to
to like a a university
and being surrounded by a lot of people
who are like at this like really like
nice university and just like man
like I got to like step up my game and
really think about like also what I'm
going to do because I'm not going to be
here for very long.
And so I started thinking about like
things like you know I'm not even
working in this field but started
thinking about like streaming platforms
like like Netflix and like Hulu and
stuff like that. It's like I don't know
how those work. I should learn how those
work and try to get to get into that
maybe. And that's kind of like what led
me down the path to actually join
distributed systems.
Mhm.
You know, and like
because I was like I asked like a bunch
of teachers. I think I asked him like my
oneonone course. I s like hey I'm
interested in like Netflix and how that
works. How do I
learn about that? And he's like, I don't
know, like maybe talk to to this
professor and talk to like, you know, I
think he like referred to like maybe
like talk to like Daryl at first. I
didn't know him at the time because I
was taking no less and then eventually
just let down like
seeing Peter's name and just like, "Oh,
maybe that will be the right class for
that." And then the rest is history.
Yeah.
Um,
but absolutely the right person to talk
to and Peter's actually worked directly
with people at Netflix uh on their chaos
engineering stuff. So, so yeah, I'm glad
that you that you discovered Peter's
class.
Yeah. And I think it really comes down
to like I I watch Netflix, so might as
well. And obviously it's software, so
maybe apply for it. It's something as
simple as that. And then also just like
obviously looking on like any kind of
job hunting website and just like maybe
that sounds cool and then apply for that
even if you feel like you're not, you
know, qualified for it,
you know? I think a lot of people worry
about that. It's just like I don't have
eight years of experience and sometimes
it's just like it's a mistake on the
application like it's a it says junior
role and it says five years of
experience and it's like that doesn't
mean anything.
Right. Right. Or like in 2005 when I was
just out when when Ruby on Rails was new
and people were asking for eight years
of Ruby on Rails experience.
Amazing.
Yeah. I mean the the the people who
write these things are are not
necessarily uh um the people who know
what's up. Um and it's funny that you
mentioned you mentioned le code. Um
which I think like so I think it's
important to keep in mind that
interviewing for a software engineering
job is a distinct skill that's different
from what you learn in school. Uh which
is you know that's un sad but true
right? what you learn in uh in a
computer science or computer engineering
undergrad degree is um you know while
while important and useful is somewhat
distinct from what you have to be good
at in order to do well in the interview
and um and and so I mean at Stanford
they even have a course um that's called
problem solving for CS technical
interviews like they they they they
actually go to the the the the trouble
of having a course that's specifically
devoted to doing well in interviews.
Um, it's like a one credit course,
right? But just just the fact that that
they that they do this um makes obvious
that interviewing is a specific skill
that you specifically need to learn. Uh
and so you know as um as as as an
academic um you know I'm I guess you
know I
back when I when I when I wasn't an
academic so I so I um I worked in
industry for about four years between
undergrad and and grad school. Um and
then uh and then I worked in an industry
research lab for a while before coming
here. Um but but I certainly found it to
be the case that um interviewing I I was
not good at at technical interviews uh
because I don't think that the interview
context did a particularly good job of
of um of showcasing uh what I what I'm
good at. Uh, and and I think that a a a
lot of people find this and they they
find that they just have to specifically
study interviewing skills in order to do
well in interviews and it's
unfortunately the case that that's not
covered in the standard curriculum.
Yeah, totally. I mean, there's many
medium blogs about how the interview
process is broken,
right?
Um, and I definitely have some thoughts
about like uh the Stanford course or
anything, but I won't really get too
much into it. Um but like yeah I think
that even is there's another layer to it
too like the academia is the way you
learn academia doesn't really directly
translate to leak code like you could
take some some 101 courses at in Santa
Cruz kind of get closer to that and 102
courses as well but it's not quite the
same and also too an earlier to that you
have a job and you want to look for
another job what you did at your job
does not translate to like the technical
interview either. It's just like this is
this weird island
and this island is the only way you can
get like money
and it's really really bizarre and I
don't really don't have a solution to
like what how it could be changed. If I
did then like I probably wouldn't uh be
I'll probably be like a recruiter or
doing like you know talks or whatever
about it. But um you know do do le codes
study them you know brush up on your
like 101 and data structures and
everything else like that. But again I
can't emphasize enough like take care of
your own mental health while doing that
because doing that in the normal
circumstances is draining and it can
only be more draining right now I would
imagine.
I I would say in addition to that, um I
think um we're we're starting to see a
lot of tech companies realize that they
can work perfectly fine without having
everybody go into the office in San
Francisco. Um and and uh we're starting
to see companies realize like we're
we're paying a lot of rent for that
office space and it's empty and all
we're we're at 80% productivity for
something so why are we paying any rent
at all.
Um and and so like one piece of advice I
would give is is I've seen a lot of of
um job offers that are 100% remote uh
just from the get-go. Um, and it's
probably worth I you know, you guys have
been doing doing this whole quarter
online and and remote and it's really
sucked, but like uh if you can take uh
any any sort of uh workflow that has
you've managed to make work for you and
and take that into your interview
process and and take that in into the
kind of uh candidate you're going to be,
um you can go live somewhere that is a
lot cheaper than Santa Cruz or the Bay
or LA or something like that, right? Um,
and if you're remote, you can still get
one of these jobs. Um, and they're
definitely still out there.
Emma, is your
The other thing I would say
Go ahead, Pete. Yeah.
Yeah. So, the other thing I would say is
it's a really good time to go into grad
school right now.
A good time to go into grad school.
Yeah. There's something
right now is a really terrible time to
be graduating from grad school.
Uh, but but it's a really good time to
be starting grad school if you're
thinking about it. Um Emma, was your
team uh for Squish remote even precoid?
Yes. Yes. Um so we couldn't most of the
team couldn't afford to stay in Santa
Cruz after graduating. So we became uh
fully remote in the middle of June and
it has been a boon for us um with like
the the quarantine started and our team
like work-wise barely noticed. Mental
health-wise we did notice. Um, but it's
um, working remotely, it's absolutely
it's its own skill. There's like all
this stuff that there's all this stuff
that you learn without even really
realizing you're learning it of working
in person with other people. And there's
a whole separate set of skills that you
have to learn to be able to work well
remotely. Um, and on like the folks on
my team have been learning that for the
last, you know, year.
Um, if if I I uh the leak code thing is
kind of uh I I don't personally think
those things are super valuable.
Um, they're not.
Yeah. Um, one of the reasons why our
team kept working after the end of the
school year was because we were all
looking for jobs. Like we we we were
looking quite frantically for jobs like
starting in April. Um, we're all still,
those of us who are still on the team
are still frantically looking for jobs,
but like there's only like if you're not
doing the work you intend to do, you
you'll lose it, you know? So, um, we one
of the things for games especially is uh
until you have a couple of years of
experience, you're basically useless.
So, that's kind of industry will will
tell you. when we went to E3, that was
the thing we were told over and over,
like just keep working on the game
because no one's going to hire you until
you have a year of experience. How do
you get a year of experience? Dh. Um, so
that that's why we kept working so that
we could keep practicing and um,
we had two people on our team who who
got hired um to another company um,
because they saw us at E3, they saw our
game and it they they took our lead
developer and our lead designer because
that's what they
that's what they were looking for. They
just kind of from our team to work on
their game which is somewhat similar.
Kind of bittersweet for you though,
right? Uh, I mean it's it's a it's a big
win for them, but uh but now you've lost
those people.
Yeah. But it it meant that the people on
our team who knew our code base pretty
well, but were sort of I guess in the
shadow of those two people who they're
they're really great people. Um they
have been able to step up. So like we we
lost our lead designer but one of our
other designers has sort of stepped into
the role and has gotten because we've
spent a year working on this project has
gotten a lot of good skills that they
can um they can apply to another job. Um
I myself have
started getting like reached out to by
recruiters like through LinkedIn of like
hey it looks like you have a lot of game
development experience because I have
listed that I've been working for a year
and a half at Brave Rave Games
and I have been like we we've been
working full-time for the last year. So,
some of it's just time. Just like keep
doing stuff and
be open to stuff that'll happen like
maintain your LinkedIn and keep
interacting with people who are in the
industry that you're interested in
working on and someone will just say,
"Hey, we need this thing and I know this
guy. Let's interview them." The
programmer that is their last day is at
the end of next week. That's exactly
what happened. um they're getting hired
onto the same team that took our lead
developer and lead designer because they
know him and they love working with him.
So as soon as there was enough money for
that for that company to hire another
person, this was the first person they
reached out to, one of the developers on
my team.
So that's that's how he was able to get
the job.
Yeah, you can't underestimate the
importance of those kinds of
connections. Um there was somebody so um
some of the students in uh in 138 here
um have I've been talking to some
students who are uh struggling in their
job search maybe they even had an offer
and then the offer was rescended because
of co 19 and so um I've been kind of
talking to people and and in some cases
helping them connect with uh with um
potential employers and um so I I spoke
to one person who had done an internship
um working with this particular niche
technology. And I talked with a friend
of mine who uh it turns out that her
team actually uses that same uh
technology and I was able to connect
them with each other and it's uh and
interestingly um uh this this uh student
in the class had actually applied to
work at this this same uh uh company
before and not heard back. Um, but then
after I made the connection and I I
didn't do anything other than saying,
"Hey, here's this person that I would
like to bring to your attention." Um,
and then the student got an interview.
So, um, I it's like it or not, um,
there's a whole lot depends on on those
kinds of personal connections
and um, it's uh, that's that that's the
reality of it.
And so it it doesn't and and I I mean I
would encourage um I it's this is so for
example I I use I use Twitter a lot and
um and I I I use it you know I I I don't
I don't feel as though I'm setting out
to do professional networking when I use
Twitter. Um like that's not why I'm
there. uh but um but it ends up being
professional networking. So I think like
like you know you should approach these
things not with uh not with the attitude
necessarily of I'm going to use this to
make professional contacts and grow my
professional network. you should
approach it with the attitude of I'm
gonna use this to learn and have fun and
then um uh or approach approach social
media with that uh attitude and then um
in the process of learning and having
fun you will uh you will meet people who
sooner or later will um uh be uh
incredibly valuable for you to know in
your career. Yeah, Twitter's great. It
also looks terrible. The um like I I I
joined Twitter in a while ago, but I
didn't start using it until like maybe
like a year or two ago and mostly now.
And tech tech and academia Twitter is
like my saving grace, you know, because
I I I moved back to LA because my home
and I also love like LA people which are
very just like
entertainment type people and just
because it's just great people watching.
But I also still wanted to be connected
to like, you know, that tech world and
everything and just like in like the
deep computer science world. So, the
best thing I do is like, okay, I'll
follow my friends on Twitter because I'm
a nerd. Uh, and I'll follow like, you
know, other people that are doing cool
stuff that they're following. And then
it just like, you know, goes from there.
And I'm just like watching people kind
of deal with their daily lives, you
know,
even outside of like, you know, what
their job is or what they're
researching, too. And then also, you
know, bring it in and then they'll often
say I see often like post or tweet um
hey we're looking for like you know
engineers now you know and then like you
could just like DM them and then they'll
realize that you're following these
people or they're your people are
following you and there's like
commonality there. So what ended up for
me, you know, like because I'm not like
really super active looking for like
another job or anything, but like
what I noticed is
this community I was kind of looking for
and everything like I kind of found
while I like you know kind of watch TV
or whatever and then like if
I wanted to reach out to anyone because
everyone it's so like casual and not
like you don't have to put on like a
suit on Twitter, you know, it's very
discouraging to put on a suit but
everyone knows that you're professional.
and everything. And it's also a great
place to share things, too. So, if you
have like a side project um or
something, you know, like, hey, post on
Twitter and maybe like I don't know,
like maybe tag someone. I don't know. It
kind of seems like, you know, you're
giving out CDs at like a show and
everything when you're like tagging
randos about like something cool, but
like you know, just like sharing like
what you're doing there and then other
people that you're following are
following them, they're like, "Hey,
that's cool, too." And then the people
that they're follow that following them
see it and then it goes from there.
But yeah,
honestly I just use Twitter to make
jokes and then
no people people like the jokes and then
they follow me and then we end up
talking about distributed systems. So
I use it to just complain about Docker.
Yeah, that's one of my main use cases
for Twitter as well.
And then other developers who are like
working at Google or something like I
also hate Docker. Come work with me.
That's kind of how it works sometimes.
Yeah.
Yeah. A while ago, um, so um, uh, I a
professor on Twitter was asking a bunch
of professors, how much time do you
spend in a given, like a bunch of CS
professors, how much time do you spend
in a given week writing code? And my
question in response will was like, are
you including time spent waiting for
Docker or not?
Because that matters,
right? And of Yeah. So, I mean, there's
a whole lot of um like haha only serious
interaction on Twitter where like you're
joking but not. Um
and but yeah, I mean I don't want to
like Twitter in many ways is a trash
fire. So, I I don't want to say that
Twitter is like this unqualified good.
Um but uh but it's been um I I think I
think Twitter has on the whole on
balance been like good for for my career
honestly just finding a comm like
whatever community you're part of you
know kind of just reaching out to that
community is probably like what I would
encourage. So if you're like part of
some sort of Discord channel
about some niche or whatever let's say
it would be like Animal Crossing because
that's just like on my mind right now.
Mhm.
Um there are people who are playing
Animal Crossing or also are software
engineers or they're project managers or
maybe they're recruiters or anything and
then you can just say, "Hey, I'm looking
for a job, you know, come to my island
and I will do an interview with you, you
know, like and then go from there." I
think that like could be a starting
point. You don't have to like do only
the traditional route. You could also
reach out to people who are like, you
know, you're in class, you're in class
with, right? your ex-classmates or you
or current classmates or whatever or
even just like alum that you find on
LinkedIn who graduated a couple years
ago, you could always reach out to me
and I'll do my best to like help you out
as well.
Um, but like don't the worst thing you
can do is just stay silent and then like
but if you like just say like hey I
graduated this is my skills.
The worst I can say is like okay I don't
know for hiring now but I'll I'll
literally I'll always do this. I'll just
DM the recruiter on Slack, are we hiring
now? And then he'll say no or yes. And
then I'll just say, okay, cool. Here's
this person's name. Regardless if he
says no or yes, and then hopefully it
sticks in his head.
Yeah, that's great. So, I guess on that
note, we're we're out of time now. So,
um we should wrap up, but but Lawrence,
thanks for the generous offer of know
offering to connect students with
people. So,
um I I um I would I would love to be
able to ask our students to reach out to
any of you um uh if you have questions
about whether it be grad school or game
engineering or looking for a job. Um
because I feel like there's a great deal
of um of of knowledge and experience um
even in people who are just one year out
from graduation um that that that they
could turn to you all for.
Yeah. I I would say also too just a
final thing and thank you for having us
too is that like
I've kept on learning a lot more after
school and I think that you should
expect that is that like oh you got your
degree that's great continue doing that
thing that you got your degree for and
you're just like I you find this like
craving of like I'm reading like this
book designing data intensive
applications it's like a fascinating
book you know
oh it's such a good book actually for so
uh the the um image on the front page of
our course website is actually taken
from the book.
That's awesome. Yeah. I mean, like, so
never stop learning, I guess, is as
cliche as it sounds, but like you're
going to have to never stop learning
because
it's how you survive in like this
industry because everything's evolving
so quickly.
I would rephrase it and I would say like
a lot of what my experience in undergrad
taught me is just how to learn the the
new skills that are really important and
that I actually use.
Yes.
Because I'm I'm
Yeah. I'm I'm learning new libraries and
new languages and new systems uh all the
time now.
Yeah. Um well, we're we are
unfortunately several minutes over time
now. I would love to continue this
conversation. It went by really fast. Um
but I want to say thanks so much to all
three of you um Emma, Lawrence, and Pete
for being willing to talk with my
students and me today. And um yeah, I
would I I'm going to share all of your
uh contact information uh with the
students if that's okay with you. Um and
and uh um thanks again for for being
willing to do this. It was lots of fun.
Thanks for having us.
Yeah, thanks for having us.
Sure thing. Yeah. All right, so um so
we're going to wrap up. Um if you're in
my class, read the map reduceuced paper
for Monday and uh have a wonderful
weekend. Take care, everyone.